hello everyone and welcome to the second
most requested game from yesterday's
round eight or rather yesterday's round
four but altogether round eight from the
julius bear generations cup first one of
course being the one where only one move
was played by magnus uh it is the game
pregnant versus magnus carlsen and it is
quite quite a brutal game no no wonder
you guys were suggesting it so much so
let's dive straight into it uh it's very
very interesting as if you've been
following what's been happening in round
one of the of the event magnus faced
terrigasi arjun nergaisi and uh he
played his robot or rather his modern
opening uh the one with the with all the
pawn moves and uh well uh arjun really
didn't know what to do with it but here
uh prague brings a very nice weapon to
deal with
carlson's weird setup so let's see what
this is all about uh prague goes for e4
we have g6 by magnus going for his
modern defense uh d4 we have d6 uh
knight to c3 and bishop to g7 we have
bishop to e3 and magnus again goes for
a6 um going for the same exact setup he
had against arjun and here arjun played
queen to d2 but proc immediately plays
h4 now which means that if magnus goes
knight to f6 prague is most likely going
to play h5 and sacrifice the exchange so
magnus has to decide does he want to go
into his preparation or does he want to
play h5 to stop this but if you play h5
then you give the knight a wonderful
atlas on g5 so it's not really great
however you play it but
i mean it's not a great opening in
itself magnus is just playing it to
prove that he is superior to everyone uh
so of course he goes for it knight to f6
he invites prague to advance the pawn
and of course he does it ponte h5 and
even though he allowed it he wasn't very
happy when prague played this there's
even a clip of this and it's a very
short one couple of seconds uh so i will
play it for you here it is
uh just for you to see uh magnus's
reaction there you have it once uh
prague pushed h5 uh he he of course uh
he saw this of course it's not a
new move for him but uh it annoyed him
very much he knew that he was gonna get
you know have to defend for pretty much
the rest of the game and against prague
that's easier said than done so okay
magnus accepts the challenge as that's
basically the only way uh you can punish
the the h5 move so knight captures an h5
and prague goes for it rook captures an
h5 g characters and queen captures an h5
we have e6 by magnus and now pawn to e5
of course hoping to open up more lines
uh towards the magnus's king so d5
magnus closes this closes the center and
now there is one game where f4 was
played but here prague just castles
queen side and it is now as of move 10
already that we have a completely new
game so how can magnus continue here he
could go for some b5 b4 ideas but he
decides to strike in the center a very
principled idea even though he's the one
whose king is uh definitely feeling the
draft uh so okay d captures on c5 and
now bishop the d7 uh now you can put the
knight for example on c6 and you've
pretty much created a nice blockade here
in the center so here f4 by prague uh
just going all mr barnes on magnus we
have knight to c6 and now knight to f3
we have queen to a5 uh and here knight
the g5 and there is no good way to
defend the f7 pawn uh but magnus of
course knew this he just wanted to get
his king to safety as soon as possible
and here of course you can't even defend
the pawn then queen captures on h7 you
will be in a lot of trouble so magnus
just castles queen side says have your
pawn i'm just gonna you know castle to
safety and of course knight captures on
f7 would be a terrible move if you do
this then bishop e8 and you've
squandered all of your advantage so
queen captures on f7 now prague is
attacking the bishop and the pawn on e6
and magnus really has to figure out how
to deal with this it's not an easy
position and magnus basically plays the
only move that keeps him in the game and
that is pawn to d4 bishop captures an e5
is also possible
but the d4 uh without too many
complications although there are quite
some uh so here bishop captures on the
four prague has to deal with this he
could also play queen captain g7 but he
decides to first
handle the d4 pawn we have knight
captures and now uh queen captures on g7
if you go for the knight which is also
possible then magnus goes into what he
had in mind bishop characters and e5f
captures and rook h2f8 and now because
the rook moved from the back rank uh the
bishop on f1 would be hanging in here
prague would have to give up the queen
but he would get quite a lot of material
for it for example rook captures now
rook captures queen rook captures on f7
and queen captures in c5 you would get
this position where magnus would have a
queen and the rook and prague would have
a rook two knights and the bishop so
basically tonight's in the bishop for a
queen which is of course
more than compensation in itself uh and
also uh carlson's king isn't as safe as
prague's king so you know
it would definitely be prague would be
better here but prague feels that he can
do even better uh he plays queen
captures on g7 and now knight to f5
attacking the queen here and now queen
to f7 uh prague not interested in queen
f6 uh keeping the knight f7 option uh
alive he goes for queen f7 right away
and now he wants to create an escape
route for uh for his queen so rook h to
f8 and now queen back to h5 we have
knight to e3 by magnus you could also go
for queen captures and c5 but he goes
for the uh traits here and now uh it
would be uh it wouldn't be all that
great if you play rook to e1 for example
because then after the the queen moved
or or even better knight knight to d5
will attack the knight and now this
knight cannot move because the rook on
e1 hangs so prague finds an even uh
better idea he already sacrificed one
exchange now he sacrifices another one
he plays rook captures on d7
and what what a game uh a rook captures
on d7 and now he plays knight characters
on e6 and this is definitely not an easy
position to be in
magnus has two rooks for for a knight in
bishop and um well it's uh his king is
wide open uh prague also has the two
connected past pawns the e and f pawn so
how can uh he play this well of course
the rook here is hanging so he plays
rook to g8 and now comes bishop to d3 uh
offering the g2 pawn but uh
there there's no easy way to to grab it
right away and plus you don't want to
give uh and give him a chance to
consolidate so he plays knight to d5 uh
and now of course knight captures on the
5 and before recapturing magnus plays
queen to e1 with check now forcing a
queen trait as this is the only move
that prague has so queen to d1 and
magnus's goes for the trade captures
captures and now rook captures on d5 and
from the position he had to this
position magnus can be
very very happy he now has um
an end game where he has two rooks
against the bishop in the night which
would usually be completely winning
however prague is up four pawns he's up
four pawns and of those four pawns the e
the f and the g pawn are past pawns and
now okay king to e2 he has to give up
the g2 pawn there's no way to save it so
king g2 and now rook captures on g2 and
here king to d7 would be much much
better for magnus but he goes rook
captures on g2 i mean who could resist
and now comes king to f3 attacking the
rook here and the magnus moves the rook
rook to h2 and now all of a sudden
prague is completely winning but he has
to play the only move that wins the game
and i know what you guys are thinking so
feel free to pause the video and find
this winning idea for prague while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always marching
your king forward and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
king to e4 i know you guys were thinking
maybe it's b4 but this is one of the
rare times it isn't so king to e4 and
this would be winning it was not played
in the game but i will just show why
it's winning because now the pawns are
marching forward there's no way to stop
this once magnus moves the rook as you
have to defend it f5 is coming if rook
h4 doesn't matter king f3 the pawns are
still marching forward the knight is
coming to the g5 for example rook f7
just knight g5 rook f8 and now f6
there's no stopping the pawns for
example rook h6 now you can't move the
pawn because this pawn hangs bishop to
f5 check if king to b8 now comes knight
captures on h7 attacks the rook for
example rook f7 king to f4 and now how
is the king to enter the game king c7
now you play e6 attack the rook and
there's no good way for the for the king
to help out with with all of these pawns
you have to play something and now even
if you try to give up the rook for two
pieces of course prague will just ignore
you and play e7 and look at this pawn
covers this square bishop covers this
square pawn covers this square they
create a wall against the black king the
black king cannot get across uh whatever
even if you give up a rook it doesn't
matter it's still completely winning the
three squares are uh unpassable for the
for the black king if rook had just king
e5 you bring the king in and it's
completely winning king c6 bishop to g6
now guarding the queening square and
after captures e8 queen this comes of
course now black has to give up the rook
captures captures and you have this
completely winning end game you're up
upon your europa full bishop of course
completely winning however prague did
not play king the e4 he did attack the
rook with the king he just played king
the g3 and now you will see how much
different it is because it is very very
hard to start pushing those pawns now
magnus plays rook h6 and already the
knight is hanging so you don't have time
to not to push pawns plus your king is
not here guarding the e5 pawn so you
can't freely advance the f5 pawn so
knight g5 now comes rook captures on c5
we have knight captures on h7 and now
king to d7 by magnus knight f6 check and
now rook captures on f6 magnus is not
about to let those pawns start marching
forward he captures and just king to e6
he will win this spawn as well king f3
king captures on f6 and knock king to e3
we have pawn to a5 and the king to d for
attacking the rook and just rook h5 and
now you have this position where magnus
is down two pawns but he has a rook
against the bishop so with perfect play
of course this will be a draw pawn to f5
now prague will first make sure that he
can never lose this and then even prague
might be the one who will be pushing for
the win so rook h6 by magnus king to d5
and now king to e7 we have pawn to a4
not allowing any pawns to ever reach b5
and now rook to c6 we have pawn to b3
and now look at the position the base of
the phone chain is the c2 pawn so guards
the b3 discards a4 the bishop here
guards the c2 pawn and the
f5 pawn so even if magnus can could have
like all the moves
you know uh he wants in a road there's
this is impenetrable so you can't get
through this so it's only prague who can
push here so king to f6 he goes king to
d4 we have king back to e7 now bishop to
e4 attacks the rook rook the c7 and now
king to e5 winning some very nice
squares here f6 is coming so rook c5
check bishop to d5 now prague still
hoping to get more than a draw he even
sacrifices one pawn to get it
rook captures on c2 and now pawn to f6
with check king d7 and now bishop
captures and b7 again winning a pawn but
now rook to e2 with chuck king f5 rook
f2 check king to g6 and now king to e6
preparing to win this pawn so bishop to
c8 with check forcing the king away king
the e5 now pawn to f7 and prague is very
very close to queening his pawn but the
king the d6
of course you first have to bring your
king closer so
but it wouldn't really matter if you
play king here then king is seven and
again both the king and the rook will be
guarding the queening square so after
king d6 we have bishop to a6 now comes
king to e7 and now bishop to c4 guarding
the pawn here rook to f6 with check we
have king to g5 we have rook back to f2
king to g4 and the rook to f6 we have
king to h5 and now magnus says all right
there's really no point in continuing
this rook captures on f7
uh bishop captures and king captures uh
of course now prague is up upon but uh
carlson's king is much closer so there's
no way to actually uh take advantage of
this king g5 king e6 we have king to f4
king to d5 king to e3 and now king to c5
we have king to d3 and now you could
play king to b4 but king to d5 is much
cooler way to do this so this is what
magnus plays king d2 king to d4 king to
c2 we have king to d5 and now king to d3
again grabbing opposition but pretty
much any movies is a draw uh king to c5
king to c3 king to d5 and now pawn to b4
we have captures captures and now king
to c6 we have pawn to a5 king to b7 and
prague finishes off with a nice a6 check
we have king captures on a6 and uh on
move 67 we have a draw by insufficient
material so what a brutal fight and what
uh what a game and i'm i'm very very
fascinated that magnus tried to employ
the the robot defense against against
again against uh
uh
another young indian grand master but
this time proc said nope we will not be
having any classical moves here just
h4h5 and you you try and defend this
robot position
which magnus most certainly tried but if
if prague found that after rook to h2
king the e4 move which i'm sure all of
you found as you know you guys are
really awesome uh it would be much much
different but yeah magnus uh grabs a
draw and he he uh
retains uh his uh uh shared a second
place uh and here are the standings so i
don't wanna forget about the standings
these are the standings so as you can
see after day two uh arjun leading with
17 points uh followed by prague
and magnus with 15 points uh vassal and
hans niemann and the youngsters will do
that with 13 and with 12 raslav
and liam lee uh those are uh the top
eight in the top eight uh will proceed
to the
uh actual event as this is only the
preliminaries then uh uh the the other
eight are vincent keimer levon aruna
nishigiri even
christopher you david navarra boris
girlfriend and adiban baskaran so if
they want to proceed to the to the final
event they of course have to be in the
top eight uh but yeah as you can see
even with the the game that he threw
against hans demon magnus still retains
very nice shirt second place if he had
played niemann and won it would be clean
first but
yeah it seems that arjun and and
pragnanda have pretty much crushed
everyone but against magnus both of them
have only scored half a point to the one
that that
prague got in this game but it was it
was very close and uh i mean if if he
found that king the e4 move it would be
it would be quite quite an impressive
game
uh but yeah that's the game what are you
gonna do hope you guys enjoyed it but
very nicely played by prague he said i'm
not having any of that stuff that arjun
played i'm going you know straight uh
straight for the head uh
basically
uh so i really really hope you guys
enjoyed this and maybe it motivates you
you know to try some of it yourself if
you encounter the the modern defense in
your online endeavors uh i would like to
thank vasudevan srinavasan and marcio de
baroche par paul sertanovich antibody
gun is damnati and francis ayer for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day